okay I guess we get started
it's my pleasure to introduce to you
today Patrick throw head Patrick's an
assistant professor in penn state's
department of ecosystem science and
management had a great conversation with
path today he has an interesting
academic background that combines
forestry fisheries and soil science he's
been at Penn State as a faculty member
for about six years he's taught in a
number of courses in national and
physical sciences there most recently
he's focusing on courses and soil
classification so genesis in urban soils
patrick's research has both basic
science and applied elements generally
speaking he examines people's use of
landscapes in the accompany changes in
soil function across larger across the
larger ecosystem that the soil
supporters pat has a really
comprehensive understanding of shale gas
issues especially as they relate to the
Marcellus Shale on Pennsylvania one of
this curb projects involves assessing
landscape change due to shale gas
drilling and devising remediation
strategies to minimize site impacts and
this is the topic that past great
presenter on today ok but you're ready
thank you very much Jim it's a pleasure
to be here at Yale today first I'm
standing here before you because of a
lot of other people and those are
colleagues of mine like Dave Mortensen
Margaret brittingham joe bishop Doug
Miller Brian bills Paul Roth and several
agencies that we've worked with our
funding has largely come through Penn
State's Marcellus enter the Heinz
foundation in Pittsburgh the US
Department of Agriculture and a
Pennsylvania bureau of forestry
department conservation natural
resources and we would not be able to
share the story today that I'm going to
share with you without that support in
those individuals and most recently
we've had some ink kind support with
data sharing from Seneca resources which
we greatly appreciate the issue i'm
going to talk about today with shale gas
development or what we call
unconventional gas
mint is an issue that not only affecting
the United States now but also the world
to a great extent and in this image you
can see the variety of sources for shale
gas to be extracted in the United States
the issue I'm going to speak about today
is specific to the Appalachians as a
whole and will thus affect areas
stretching from New York State down into
Kentucky through West Virginia Maryland
and Pennsylvania for those of you who
aren't familiar with unconventional gas
development the largest difference with
conventional gas development is the way
the drilling and the depth of the
drilling occurs and just schematic which
you probably can't read basically shows
a multiple casing system going all the
way down to 5,000 feet which is then
turned the lateral line horizontally
when shale gas development was first
started the bulk of it was vertical
drilling such as was done in Texas what
changed was the horizontal drilling that
was the technological technological
achievement that made the ability to
move to larger distances away from that
payout at the top of the location
feasible for economic extraction cobble
with the ability to explore exploit that
formation that depth via the hydrologic
Hydra hydraulic fracturing process I'm
not going to go into a lot of that today
that's a topic outside of my realm and
there's plain information on the web
about it but the point to make is the
area that's most affected from the
standpoint that I deal with personally
is right up here at the very top and
that's the area that most people who
deal with this issue as a landowner
basis are thinking about that's
important to recognize because there's a
significant disconnect and thinking
between what an industry is typically
worried about which is this versus what
the homeowners are worried about where
the land managers are worried about
which is this or that aquifer without
drinking water is available when that
vertical and horizontal well is going
into production you have a lot of
activity on a area very large and this
is one of the other most important
factors to take away from this lecture
today is the extent of the change on the
landscape is one of the most important
things
that we've recognized as occurring in
Pennsylvania compared to traditional
drilling or to conventional drilling
you're looking at an area in size of
about five acres this could have been
virgin forest three weeks prior once the
drilling process is underway you
literally have as Jim Rick and our fur
from the srbc Susquehanna River Basin
says an orchestra of activity occurring
on the pad and it really is in Orchestra
activity in the sense that you have
numerous people involved on this pad and
even all the way down in Houston Texas
controlling the drilling operation and
mining the drilling as is occurring it's
a pretty incredible technological feat
what they can do at the end of the day
you have at the surface the one pad with
numerous horizontal lines going out and
as these horizontal lines that are then
pulling the gas once that shell has been
fractured back to the surface to then a
feeder line or a transmission line which
moves that gas from the pad to a larger
continental federal line as we call them
well I'll be speaking about today at a
terrestrial challenges facing shale gas
development in the Appalachians and in
Pennsylvania from the standpoint of
landscape management the two biggest
limitations we're dealing with first
involved soil limitations the
Appalachians don't have the history they
have because it's easy to farm them if
it was you'd have an incredibly
different economy Appalachia is was
today because of its soil and that soil
is some of the hardest in the world to
manage it's wet it's rocky it's shallow
to bedrock it's got a lot of relief
there's a lot of steep slopes and you
have a subsurface restrictive layer at
about a half a meter in many places
called a fragile pan this is a sub soil
horizon which can perch water in turn
roots because of the soil limitations
Appalachia is largely faced a resource
extraction economy from timber Doyle to
guess and it will likely always face a
resource extraction economy unless some
other way is found to manage that land
to make it productive economically once
that pad site is cleared there's a
couple of options that can be done but
one of the things that we were first
curious about when we were looking at
this issue is what are the
characteristics of the sites where as
the landscapes are being developed
about half of the site's we're finding
our fairly rough sites which are
reflected across regular generally
across Appalachia small percentage them
were formerly disturbed areas a porter
of them are rocky steep or low fertility
sites one to two percent tend to be very
sandy sites which is usually confined to
just a couple of the geologic formations
in Pennsylvania and about fifteen
percent of them have that subsurface
horizon that can restrict water movement
so about half would be fairly
challenging soils to use to begin with
and this is important to think about
because if we're going to be thinking
down the road about Reclamation what
will be the ideal soil condition we're
starting with right now if we look at
the better sites alright we're starting
to find sites that might have more
moisture but in this case they have too
much moisture so almost a quarter of the
sites have some type of water table
problem that's either a shallow regional
water table or a perch water table
condition so these are sites that if
they're developed could pose a problem
on the landscape from a hydrologic
perspective or in reclamation could pose
a significant challenge and how we
reconstruct that functional soil
hydrologic system at the end of the day
you've got about thirty two percent of
soils that are being developed that are
pretty good Appalachian soils for
reclamation they might have low
fertility but they don't have
significant challenges because of
drainage or rockiness in about eighteen
percent are good soils you might need a
little bit of an amendment when you're
reklame ting reklame ting that site or
you might have to do some extra bulk
density remediation obviously if you
have significant compaction but about
eighteen percent of those soils are
pretty good so to point to take home
from this message here is a lot of the
soils at the end of the day after
they've been significantly disturbed are
still going to be pretty challenging
soils to deal with from a reclamation
perspective after the soil challenge in
Pennsylvania the second largest
challenge facing development in
Pennsylvania is the relief and here we
have Bradford County and a transect
stretching across Bradford County from
the Northwest to the southeast here and
this is just to give you an example the
extent that a relief across that area
the most common comment we heard from
the gas companies from Texas when they
arrived in Pennsylvania was wow this
place is hilly and it's wet and that's
hard to deal with if you're not used to
it and they had some significant
problems early on
in learning how to deal with these
landscapes and the seasonal changes in
moisture that occurred on these
landscapes this becomes a problem
because once these landscapes with high
relief experience the moisture soil
materials once loosened start to move
around and once they're moving around it
can end up in water bodies as
sedimentation and cause problems in
those adjacent streams so we are curious
about the sites being developed where
they were occurring on a hill slope
position and whether that hill slope
position has a tendency to converge
moisture and become wetter or tended to
shed water to begin with alright so
starting out what we find is about 66 to
almost ninety percent of the sites are
on these back slope isla positions and
of those about thirty percent are in
these landscape positions that could
receive moisture alright that doesn't
mean they have a water table problem but
they have a high potential for a water
table problem because they're converging
moisture in that landscape position if
we then look at the risk on these steep
slopes to surface water movement and
what B and PS are being implemented what
best management practices are being
implemented of some of these high-risk
landscapes we're starting now to look at
the potential for erosion and sediment
control problems that the BMPs might not
be addressing pennsylvania's stormwater
management was never designed to handle
a situation like this this is a gas line
developed across part of an area near
Waterville Pennsylvania you literally
have over 200 meters of landscape clear
at about 45 feet wide across the slope
greater than twenty-five percent and
this was barren from November to April
this is basic soil mechanics basic
agronomy you don't have to be a
scientist to know this isn't a good
thing to have bear for that long of the
year and this is an exception to the
norm we don't see a lot of this but the
fact we see some of this is what keeps
me awake at night when a large storm
system like hurricane sandy or tropical
storm islands coming up the coast
because if one of these lets loose
that's when you have a significant
landslide risk once reclaimed this is
what it's going to look like that's the
same site in midsummer okay so still a
significant slope functionally that's
going to be a different landscape
does that matter a lot of what we were
doing early on we're first exploring the
issue of shale gas development was
documenting the problem you found a new
disease you document its characteristics
then you start looking at the basic
science questions how is this different
from what we know has occurred before
and other types of disturbances if we
start to look at those slopes where
development has occurred in Pennsylvania
we find that most of the area is being
developed for pads are not on steep
slopes a small percentage of them are
ten percent those are ones to pay
attention to because if you're cutting a
pad a flat pad into a hill slope you're
going to have what's called a high wall
which is what you see in a strip mine so
you've got this big chunk of bedrock and
soil sticking up but you have to
stabilize or it could slump over right
and when you reclaim that area back in
you've got to reproduce that original
contour move all that material back you
know if you dig a hole put the soil back
what happens now also all fits in the
hole because you've added more porosity
so now you got to deal with slumping
unless you achieve an adequate
compaction with your soil mechanics so
ten percent of the sites are going to be
ones we're going to really want to watch
but overall where the pads are going is
not the problem they're mostly going on
flat landscape positions it's the
pipelines and the roads that you're
going to see they are the potential
problem if you look at Pennsylvania
soils as a whole and you start to look
at a parameter in the NRC soil database
called runoff class you can use this as
a way to look at one of the worst case
conditions assault might face if we look
at runoff class in relation to slope
there isn't always a direct relationship
you can have a worse runoff class and be
on a shallower slope because when you're
looking at the runoffs class you're
looking at a saturated soil that's bear
so worst case scenario and this is what
starts to make us nervous now because
we're realizing that we have seventy
percent or more of our soils that are
medium or worse runoff class and this is
a typical type of condition if that site
is being developed there's no vegetation
is compacted it's very easy to saturate
up the littlest soil that's there that
had a porosity to begin with so now we
start seeing that even though we may be
on these gentle sloping areas we have a
problem we have to worry
about Pennsylvania geology Bureau of
geology has developed a landslide risk
map in this case the redder areas have a
higher landslide risk if you look at the
distribution of where to guess is being
developed in Pennsylvania you see a
fairly large chunk is in these areas
prone to landslides risk so you start
adding the story together with the slope
problems there surface runoff you start
to see there's some potential in some
areas for some significant challenges
for landslides in these areas are being
developed in the southwestern part of
state in this part of the state you
still have an area you need to pay
attention to it has a lower risk but
because we're developing those slopes
that might have those pipelines going up
them now we've got areas we need to
focus on for monitoring more and we know
these are not uncommon these tropical
storms are not uncommon anymore in the
mid-atlantic we're seeing in
Pennsylvania higher frequencies of
higher precipitation events period
doesn't have to be a tropical storm last
summer was absolutely bizarre with the
intensity of the thunderstorms we had so
if we have these more frequent higher
intensity precipitation events you now
need to see hmm is my BMP that I've
designed for a system prior to a
potential climate change episode
adequate to address a climate change
induced system or do we need to canoe
bmps to address erosion sedimentation
risk with this changing climate there
are several characteristics of shale gas
that make it unique as a resource
extraction footprint compared to others
like coal strip mining etc and one that
is classic is the rapid pace of that
development until this year essentially
had logarithmic growth almost this year
is the first year we saw a dip alright
so this is as of this week's data we saw
a decline in production for the first
time in the number of wells going in so
what we're thinking now is we'll
probably see some steady development
trend may be a spike every now and again
but we're probably at a fairly steady
state number of wells going in annually
for some time in the foreseeable future
and then one of the reasons and the
dominant reason really why this decline
occurred was because the pricing
plummeted and that's because we got too
good at extracting gas for a market that
did not exist where the wells are going
about 93% of development is on private
land that's the problem Pennsylvania
because Pennsylvania's missa pallies
rule there's no centralized land
planning in Pennsylvania so if you're
going to control development if you're
going to try to enforce statewide
restrictions you've got to go about it
via state law that affects the
construction aspects you can't centrally
plan in that area of development we're
seeing about half in court for us about
half an Ag and the areas are being
developed an Ag a lot of that will go
back into some type of production
following the major chiral major
hydrologic basins affected in the state
our first two Susquehanna and then the
Monongahela and Allegheny alright we're
seeing more and more development in the
hollow hio though because of the
prevalence of the wet gas down that part
of the state but the Susquehanna basin
by far is the largest affected very
little in the Delaware River Basin
largely because of the risk to the water
source or water users in this part of
the state and there's a lot of
management planning going on now with
the Delaware River Basin Commission in
Pennsylvania recreation industry is
paramount to the economy and fishing and
hunting or two of the biggest there's a
lot of concern in a Susquehanna River
Basin with the class a trout streams in
these areas and there's very little
that's been done to Monterey be so far
because there isn't a lot of funding for
it yet but if you look at the prevalence
of these class a trout streams in
relation to the development there's a
potential for these areas which are
typically headwater streams a lot of
them in core forest areas to be
negatively impacted by development if
the BMPs fail the SRB see which is the
organization that monitors water
withdrawals within the Susquehanna River
Basin estimates that about 30 million
gallons a day consumptive use will just
be associated with the Marcellus
formation alone that does not include to
Utica this is about what a nuclear power
plant uses in a day and during the peak
we were looking at about 4.4 million
gallons withdrawn / well development
right now that's about a third to a
fifth of that value because the well
development has really slowed down in
the state the other significant
challenge that we're seeing to
understanding shale gas development of
Pennsylvania and its footprint across
the state is it's dispersed pattern this
makes it very hard to get an idea on the
big picture effect that will have on
Appalachia and the state this dispersed
patterns a lot like wind Pennsylvania's
energy portfolio is a multi-faceted
portfolio now coal natural gas
conventional unconventional wind nucular
geothermal there's a wide variety of
energy sources here you see an example
of a freshwater holding pond used for a
fracking operation alright this is a
typical site now you see across
Appalachia in Pennsylvania the third
major factor unique about shale gas
extraction compared to the other
resource extractions we've seen in the
past is the degree of its effect on the
landscape and this is likely to have a
lasting effect on the landscape other
light unlike other resource extraction
periods we've seen in Pennsylvania's
history but it's important to recognize
shale gas extraction is not equated to
West Virginia's mountaintop removal or
strip mining is not the conventional
shallow gas development you see
typically all across Appalachia but it's
not 1880 again we're not going to
clear-cut Pennsylvania it's not a Derek
and every three feet certainly it's
going to have an effect and that effect
is going to be dramatic we know that
already but it's not going to be the
1880s there are many processes that
occur as app as being developed which
affect that landscape and the resources
on that landscape from the clearing of
the site initially to the initial
construction of a flat surface this may
or may not turn into be a pad down the
road you just don't know unless you're
with a company sometimes pads later on
that become a well pad our first uses
staging area for equipment this pad
access roads that are developed there's
a lot of grading it occurs to level a
site good example of that slope
challenge we have here's an example of
pad with a well or what's called a
Christmas tree this would be an example
of one of those small transmission lines
moving from a pad to a main federal line
the freshwater pond and then it was an
example of what a reclaimed pad looks
like here
this is one a few pictures you'll see if
I really a reclaimed pad because we're
just not going to be reclaiming pads for
a long time to come right along the edge
of that pad like any disturbance you're
going to see some migration of the pad
because of wind throw because now you
have a gap in the forest it will behave
like any other forest to gap you know
respond to win 3 over time as tree death
occurs and wind movement continues all
I'm going to get into that yep basically
has to do with the cost of developing
that pad and access to that pad down the
road if you have to refract so if you
have to refract you need that space and
that space is is a lot of money for
every pad built the Nature Conservancy
did a study and they estimated that
about 12 hectares is disturbed we did a
study where we used national
agricultural imagery from the USDA and
we found that four pads that were not
reclaimed which were about 1081 the pad
footprint was about 5.1 hectares the
disturbance associated with that pad was
a meeting of about 2.2 but look at the
max we found one that was as large as 20
point five hectares and this was one of
the areas where you're starting to see
larger and larger pad development at the
cost of fewer pads so less fragmentation
or landscape more wells though on that
pad on areas that have been reclaimed we
actually found 202 paths that had been
reclaimed this was back in two thousand
seven the median pad sighs after elect
nation was about a tenth of a hectare
alright median with disturbance around
it so access road transmission line was
about point four hectares and the max
size left behind was 3.3 so let's see
you're looking at about five acre or
let's see two hectares five acres right
so that okay over 75 percent of wear
pads still have less than three wells
per pad that's a problem because you
still have a lot of pads
that could have been filling occurred
that's why the pads aren't being
reclaimed we are seeing a trend though
in the last two years with larger pads
being built with more Wells on them the
total Marcella's build out the Nature
Conservancy estimates is going to be
6,000 to 15,000 paths with about four
two wells for 210 wells per pad and this
could be an area disturbed of about 180
thousand hectares compared to the amount
of abandoned stripped lines strip mines
we have in Pennsylvania is a far greater
number and that's just abandoned
strychnine so that's not active strip
mine so from a landscape disturbance
perspective we're looking at something
equally if not more significant than
strip mining history in Pennsylvania
which is a whole book of itself there's
a distinct difference between how
private lands and public lands are
developed on public lands you see a lot
of disks here's your old forested road
alright and you have a sister gas and
water line right adjacent to it the goal
of this is to decrease fragmentation ok
on private lands is where we see the
most new road building going into areas
that they want to develop so pipeline
and road development not pad development
seems to be the seed seems to be the
greater factor we've seen that could
disrupt the landscape down the road and
the character of this landscape prior to
development here's a typical
Pennsylvania Forest Road and this is a
minor alteration to that road to allow
gas trucks to access all right we're
typically seeing these widened further
now because the equipment's so large
they're finding that for long-term
seasonal maintenance they need a wider
Road base so they don't have the
drainage problems they have with the
encroachment on these narrow older gas
rows so this we an example of an older
modification the newer roads we're
seeing are a bit wider than that but
this is going to have a different
hydrologic characteristic if there's one
thing you've noticed throughout these
pictures the shell gas roads are gray
and that's because a lot of times you're
using limestone that they're bringing up
from the ridge and valley province onto
the plateau to cap the roads and that
limestone is going to have a higher pH
and the dust generated from that higher
ph limestone is going to drift into the
adjacent forest and that can have an
effect of essentially
liming those soils these Appalachian
surface cells can have PHS as low as
three point three to four point two into
surface soils that will have a lining
effect and we're finding through
research with Dave Mortensen in our
group that it might have an effect on
invasive species promotion yes yes for
the company's mean yes so one thing we
were interested in looking at was the
effect on development on Pennsylvania
score forest because these are some of
the last intact forested areas in the
Appalachians they're important areas for
a lot of migratory species here you see
a model of the core forest in
Pennsylvania which would be anywhere
over a hundred meters from a non
forested area so it's essentially an
interior forested area and you see a
model of where the well distribution or
pad distribution is in Pennsylvania and
what we find is that like the landscape
analysis we did about half of the
developments and non forested areas in
those forested areas about twenty-five
percent is in the core okay the
remainder is occurring in these areas
that have some prior nearby disturbance
whether its edge or an interior gap in
that forested area so twenty-five
percent of develop developments been
occurring in these interior forest areas
where you have a lot of these
neotropical migrants species so right
now there's a lot of research going on
looking at the effect of the development
whether it's sound or proximity to
disturbance in these areas where you
have these core forest environments and
these neotropical 'he's the impact
that's been found so far on the avian
community specifically with conventional
unconventional development is that we're
seeing some relocation of species that
have a high site preference and we see a
higher homogenous a shin of species as
they fill in that gap or edge habitat
we're finding evidence of hydrologic
capture associated with development and
this is going to result in some areas of
the landscape becoming wetter and some
areas becoming dryer when I first got
involved in the project this was
literally the first thing I did the day
I was asked to become part of this
research team they got our lidar data
and I ran a wetness index model of an
area where I knew there was a pad and I
said wow this could be really
interesting because what you see in this
picture is a model showing areas at a
landscape that potentially are wetter
which are blue and areas of the
landscape is potentially our dryer that
are red so one of our basic questions
was was can we use this information in
the field to look at changes and soil
moisture and soil carbon associate with
development changes in nutrient pools
there's a whole host of potential
research tech research projects here
dealing with hydric soils loss of
wetlands hydrologic capture so this will
be an example where you might have a
flow path originally moving across this
part of the landscape that no longer
exists we use this model and a couple of
examples with private landowners so the
slope in this case is going towards the
top of the screen the wetness model here
is showing an area with a seep across a
property boundary line which runs right
here you have a stone wall running up
this part of the property and what the
wetness model is showing is the
existence of the previous seep and a
document potential for soil moisture
movement and surface water movement
along that stone wall which was
confirmed by the landowner this outline
shows where the pads going to be
developed and the red dot is where the
well is this is an example where you can
see the actual pad built right on the
property line and there's the old seep
okay there's a trailer right next to the
pad and then here you see the effect of
surface flow that was rerouted from that
stone wall now down the adjacency of the
pad into the guys barn on the other
property and he had to sandbag his barn
to prevent the surface runoff from
storms going into his barn so this is
not rocket science this is something
that soil scientist geologists
hydrologists have been doing for decades
as long as a DM has been around the
thing is getting companies to use this
as a planning tool that's valuable
because that could have stopped the
lawsuit we've also started to exploit
the lidar data in Pennsylvania and
essentially done a reverse flow
accumulation or reverse button asst
index and in this case what we're doing
is looking at the effect of hydrologic
capture from the placement of
infrastructure and what you're seeing
here is the white area shows areas of
landscape where water that would have
flowed is no longer flowing because that
structure was built and what you see is
that there are good pads
and there are bad pads all right some
pads are going to have very little
effect on the surface hydrology and we
notice we've measured this in the field
other pads are going to cause a problem
the question is how big of a problem
what's downslope that that moisture is
no longer reaching is it a wetland that
was depending upon that moisture all
right is there as endangered species is
there a teeny species so one of the
questions we have now is how can we use
this information to better look at
wetland research surface runoff research
amphibian migratory pathway research or
teeny species loss how the
infrastructure is going in on the
landscape is dependent upon the geology
and the surface characteristics all
right this is really going to be
dependent upon the land managers
perspective right the dcn are the
private landowner who's thinking about
their streams their forests the
integrity of those communities the gas
companies those thinking about the depth
the thickness the integrity of that
formation its flatness lack of faults
okay what we have to do is figure out if
we can synergize these perspectives and
this is difficult to do because the
changing economics and technology that
the industry is experiencing just since
2003 is tremendous in what they're able
to do now in Pennsylvania what we can do
now in Pennsylvania you could not do in
Texas during the peak of the boom there
and what we can do in Pennsylvania can
do a lot to decrease landscape
disturbance the factors that are out of
our control gas pricing drilling
technology water supply management
technology these are the things that
companies have to think about because of
the bottom line and you may have the
best idea in the world to help protect
the landscape but if it does not help
the bottom line is probably not going to
get done there's some interesting
aspects of this when you think of
protection of environmental resources
all right the DCNR has this policy of
avoid minimize mitigate and monitor all
right their success is largely in pre
lease planning gating and amber for any
development occurs the TNC Nature
Conservancy is trying to work with
companies to develop this design tool
which will help guide design that's
difficult to do but they're having some
success with it the Marcellus coalition
which is represented by all the
companies has come
with their recommended practices which
is a collection of practices taken from
the literature that are pre-existing if
we look at what Pennsylvania is doing by
law you have a permanent process that
largely is built on landscape
disturbance and TD species this has
really been good in some respects
because we know a lot more about the
wildlife species in Pennsylvania and
their distribution but because it's
project focus we don't have a bigger
picture effect yet because we're looking
at this pad and what's going to happen
there in this pad what's going to happen
there the bottom line when we're trying
to reclaim a water holding pond like
this 17 million gallon freshwater pond
is that we know what we need to do what
we need to do to get it done right is
change human behavior I argue that we
need no more research to know how to
reclaim this site we know how to do it
we have the money to do it we just have
to get the money to the landscape to do
it pads we now know may have operational
lives of decades instead of months or
years and this could significantly delay
reclamation efforts and the reason why
these pads are going to be around
because they're expensive to build it's
hard to get a lease those wells are
going to be productive for quite a while
and those wells may need to be refract
if they need to be refract they need the
space to get the equipment back on that
pad while the pads may not be at a point
of reclamation there's a lot of other
infrastructure that is the key thing is
to think about everything I've talked
about with the site the soils the
landscape slope etc because now you're
looking at a case-by-case basis for
reclamation here are some good examples
this is a site post reclamation failure
success failure right what happened here
was they got done in November seeded the
site and you only have the South aspect
here that took you don't have the
seventy percent cover but a year later
you're good are you going to crack down
on this company that's a tough case to
argue because it's not necessarily their
fault that the season did not allow
germination you know in November you can
get some success it's tricky but you can
but if you go in you start playing
hardball with the companies and start
throwing down finds the fines are so low
why pay them maybe now I have yet to see
bini not do a best effort to get this
done right and if you go back and look
to say today it's pretty good it's not
great but it's pretty good this is the
poster child in Pennsylvania this was
forest before it was this okay the
landowner here invested a lot of money
to plant these trees and each tree is
hand dug into the pads former area so
this was a high wall and all the soil
was put back and a tractor d6 i think it
was ran back and forth across the site
to compact it is this reclamation
effective in achieving a function
similar what was there before and does
it matter that it does not this is
private land this person can do what
they want is that adequate for ecosystem
protection in some of these areas where
we have these less passages of core area
pipeline soil analysis in this case all
right this is the soil left over when
the pipeline was built soil pH not too
bad alright pretty low nutrients what
they're recommending is that you apply a
high amount of nutrients in this case
over three miles of pipeline for every
acre you should apply 12,000 pounds per
acre of lime to achieve a nutrient
success for germination of perennial
cover to meet the seventy percent cover
requirements for dep that's a lot of
effort that's a lot of money is there a
better way to do this we know if you
start lining these soils that you're
going to have a risk of promoting
invasive species this is the research I
was telling you about before who did
some of this work looking at the risk of
these liming of these soils that are
traditionally low pH if we start looking
at the physical effects here's some
interesting results this is a table
coming from the USDA NRCS urban soil
planning manual and this shows four
different soil textures what would be an
ideal mass of soil per volume or bulk
density one that might limit root growth
and one the outright restricts root
growth and for the soils that we're
going to be looking at in Pennsylvania
we're looking in this area so anything
around 1.55 we're going to start
worrying about now we have a tool we can
go into a site pre or post reclamation
make some
minson know if we're going to have a
problem down the road this is powerful
if you're if you're setting up a lease
you can actually put numbers in your
lease now that tells that company if you
don't achieve this post reclamation it's
not a successful reclamation you have to
do something about it we went back to
the historical gas development that was
going on in 1930s up by Allegheny
National Forest and we looked at 12 gas
pads in there a Saudi associated native
condition and we went back into the
aerial imagery and tried to look for any
disturbance since that area was built
this was kind of hard to do because we
didn't have aerial photography forever
every single year for but for what we
know for these sites for the most part
there was no disturbance and we looked
at the cat pad composition that was used
or left behind when these sites were
built and what we found is if we look at
the surface bulk densities we do see a
significant difference between the gas
pad in the forest in the bulk density
and if we look at the subsurface bulk
density down to 20 centimeters and this
is typically the area are going to look
for route restrictions we see a
significant difference but the important
thing is for these soils you're not
meeting the route restrictive barrier
these are all non-limiting bulk
densities for producing trees so for
these sites that howard boot put it in
the 1930s and the manner they were which
is literally just mounting up about a
foot of soil for the small gasp ad like
the size of this area of chairs today
you don't have a bulk density problem
those soils that would limit tree growth
in fact there's a lot of trees growing
in these areas if you go to a pipeline
just put in and measure that a couple of
months after it was put in here we have
the surface bulk density then five
centimeters ten centimeters fifteen and
twenty pipeline in the forest and the
significance value we see a significant
significant difference across all values
we see root restrictive differences at
10 to 20 centimeters on the pipeline and
these are hot you know if you're in a
drought condition you're going to have a
problem with perennials in some of these
cases so what have we learned from
Pennsylvania well compared to past
resource extraction disturbance shale
gas is going to have a unique footprint
okay secondly that footprint is
exhibiting a very rapid and extensive
and dispersed pattern and this is very
hard for land manager
and regulators to deal with you have an
incredibly complex mix of public and
private land issues and at the end of
the day this is really a private land
issue because all the sites I've shown
you only two of these sites are private
lands that we're working with everything
else is state land we're seeing a pretty
substantial threat to these core forest
areas which again are some of the last
messages of these areas left in the
Appalachians and there's an invasive
species risk in these areas too with
species becoming predominant that
weren't we know a lot about reclamation
we know a lot about how to fix these
areas and make them better we know about
the risks to going into these areas now
the bottom line is to be successful at
the end of the day at addressing this
problem what we have to do is change
human behavior it's that simple it
really is if the challenge though is the
economics behind the situation are not
in our control what we have realized is
this as an amazing opportunity to
educate a lot of people about ecosystems
and that's been a great thing for
Pennsylvania because this area being
developed is a documented food desert by
the USDA that means there's no food
production within certain distance of
your house there's grocery stores I have
closed during the boom okay these have
some of the toughest education problems
in the state of Pennsylvania is in this
area of the state you look at any town
in this area where the gas developments
occurring and this was a boom town for
two other extraction periods in the
history you know Jim's town alone has
experienced significant economic
problems in Pennsylvania it was a
logging town that was started originally
it was one of the Keystone towns in
Pennsylvania all right and they're
crashing again so the money is not all
staying in PA what we've done to try to
educate Pennsylvania citizens some more
and now others in ass palacios develop
this electronic field guy which
addresses a lot of these terrestrial
concerns and depth if you have any
questions about what I've talked about
there's probably some answers in here I
would be happy to address them thank you
the gas as I know that think you can
take up the guest room
the dozen years possibly and I know we
talked about earlier one of these
companies because of imposter something
here and it allows to be gone maybe in
10 years ago business whatever so what
happens to the gap the pads they're
owned by the companies that go out of
business are they but they've been
bought and then it's a whose
responsibility is it to do the
reclamation at that point so sites are
bonded so bonding is a solution to that
problem so there's a lot of sites in
Pennsylvania you know you go to dep
database and you'll see is like you know
at least 300,000 gas wells in
Pennsylvania there's probably 100
thousand holes in the ground we don't
even know what they are just not
document right in those cases like with
a lot of acid mine drainage problems
there's no money to fix that problem
because there was no money sit down
ahead of time that if they didn't come
back and fix that they weren't going to
get their money back that's what a bond
does and so a lot of these sites are
bonded so as I understand it even if the
company's trade hands there's still that
bonding that has to be laid down that
may be wrong but i'm i'm pretty certain
that's what I've heard so I know if
you're the company that hasn't traded
hands there's definitely bonding down
for the reclamation environment
effective that I you tacos continuation
groundwater how
is that I talked about how really how
many cases racine so I'm a groundwater
hydrologist but early on the problems
that we have in Pennsylvania were
because of unlined wells up in the
northeastern part of the state that were
affected by shallow methane migration so
you've got multiple lithologies as you
drill down through the flatbeds of
Pennsylvania there's shallow gas trapped
up I and when the drilling occurred that
methane was allowed to migrate and
because Pennsylvania has some pretty
lacks casing laws for it swells that
contaminated drinking water now what the
companies do is they will go around they
will test everyone's water before they
drill and they will have a record of
that water test I was in the assumption
they give that test to the homeowners
but I learned tonight that not all the
homeowners are getting them but they do
do this I've had friends have shown up
and company asked can we test your water
and they'll take that water test then if
there's a problem later on the company
can back and say well you needn't have
that water problem before that's our
fault or I'll know you had methane your
water prior now I do know a lot of
companies will notify the homeowner if
they do find a problem so maybe the ones
that aren't are the ones that don't have
problems but if you have a methane
problem I'm almost certain you'll find
out before any drilling occurs just so
the company will protect itself as far
as I know and this is what I've heard
numerous conferences from state federal
and gas company says there isn't yet but
I know there's a couple of cases now
being examined where there's a
documented case of groundwater
contamination from fracking in the
United States is there a way of
designing path so that must disruptive
as they're sitting on still
soon the current design was based on
practicality or something performs the
function for drilling as opposed to
surfaces ruption you might be able to
get something would you both so what
we're seeing in the last couple of years
of some really innovative ideas that
we're just starting to explore a couple
of companies now will bring in external
materials manufactured materials
essentially padding so they don't have
to disturb as much subsoil because
remember what happened when the economy
collapse as well as prices the gas went
through the roof and like every time
you're hauling rock every time you're
hauling water or every time you're
hauling stone that peg gets more and
more and more expensive the bill and so
if they can use this material pick it up
and they're done move to the other pad
there's less moving of the soil they're
gonna have to do after the fact so
that's one thing we've seen a lot of the
frack water they actually have
evaporator units they've designed on pad
to get rid of the water to produce solid
so they can truck the solids off the
site so they are incredibly innovative
at solving problems to save money one of
the big solutions to trucking water has
been to build pipelines right so there's
a mixed blessing you saw what the
pipelines can do but you know if I had a
kid up in that area and i'm looking at
truck chips and how fast some of those
trucks go now i'm thinking how many
trucks might that one pipeline replace
well i can give you an idea one pipeline
that went in north of waterville
replaced i believe it was 50,000 truck
trips for the development at gas field
area and it paid for itself in six
months and not one kid was hit by a
water truck so it's real mixed that the
point that you're making is
Tennessee then to do all this stuff by
transporting stuff by pipelines whether
bringing in fresh water and how about
getting rid of all the bad water that
comes from the that I'm going to take it
out by the structure is there a pipeline
for that as well I have not seen first
hand so that would be flowback water
water comes out that water is most often
recycled it's putting a tanker and that
tanker is carried to another well for
the flowback water yes so somewhere
around three to fifteen percent of the
water comes back out of the well as
flowback water and that water is highly
contaminated cannot be discharged in a
municipal treatment plan anymore they
were doing that originally that water
dole I would be done to a sea lion that
refers on degrade them if they can use
that as as water elsewhere they'll do
that first because they got to truck it
all the way to Ohio yeah and I have not
kept up off with the youngstown problems
there were there was some seismic
problems dealing with injection wells in
Ohio from water from Pennsylvania so
I've not kept up with what's happening
with that now but I do know that if they
can reuse that water around that site is
far cheaper to do that and truck it out
there looking at barging it down the
Ohio River i dunno i heard that the
other day
because of the problem with yep to do
sex you mentioned the earth movements as
a potential risk
the pictures of actual events
disturbed environment are you seeing
that
thinking greater risk is any conjugated
high service events
pieces and a fine sediment particular
transport to and yes you have chronic
bleeding of soil and that varies by site
and it varies by company some companies
I can say I've not seen any evidence of
any material moving off site it's
amazing how good they are others aren't
as good at that all of them have to
follow storm water in erosion control
plants but the problem in the last
couple of years has come aside with the
boom has been the types of storms we've
been getting and the time of year that
the operations have gone in you got
remember when they came in to
Pennsylvania originally they were not
used to this type of development in this
type of climate saw thaws alone are
tremendous erosion and sedimentation
events than the one we just had
certainly caused problems that we saw in
a couple of places is there anything you
can do about that other than shut them
down during those periods that's your
only alternative but even if you shut
them down how is that going to be
effective to try even predict that thaw
environment you basically have to say
once November comes you're not working
until post spring once that soil dries
out DP recommends in Pennsylvania that
the soil not be worked if you can take a
sample in your hand and form a ball how
many months of the year could you work
soil in Connecticut with that rule it's
the same number in Pennsylvania maybe
two right so you're going to give them a
two-month window to work so we are
seeing chronic problems ninety-nine
percent of those are human behavior one
percent are those punctuated periods of
disequilibrium thrown at us by mother
nature when you just happen to have a
lot of landscape in a condition that you
just don't want a big storm event
sitting over you just hope that that
doesn't occur when one of those sites is
open like that you know now there are
monitoring stations being put in along
numerous headwater in larger tributary
environments along the plateau these are
being put in in the Susquehanna basin
specifically by the srbc and they are
measuring conductivity
I think they're doing some type of
sedimentation measurement too I don't
know if a CG disc type of measurement or
something but they can measure events
from upstream and try to clue in on
whether it has been some type of
activity from shale gas development in
that area that's posed a problem the
biggest problem we have is just
maintenance you know silk socks not
being cleaned out the storm water basins
not being cleaned out the BMP not put in
right right so what you need is this
better instruction I think and then some
monitoring maybe with a little more
teeth you know you can drill a hole
5,000 feet this way three to nine
thousand feet that way right I think
there's enough technology and smart to
do a better job at the surface so slide
that compared the amount of water used
to yes and I was wondering if you could
if you have an equivalent in
I'll top of my head no but Jim Rick and
der fur with the srbc might be the guy
to ask that question of he might be able
to do that for you it's just during the
time of the fracking so forth right
that's not going to continue for the
life of the pad right the water for
being pretty is a lifetime you know I
guess one argument I could see a gas
company using in pennsylvania's well
given the prevalence of water in the
state how big of an issue is it that's 1
i've heard a lot of but i know you know
srbc just recently used to do to this
low-flow policy in pennsylvania across
all users where our flows and streams
reach a certain level you can't withdraw
anymore which is great because there is
evidence there's been some cases where
literally water was being withdrawn from
a stream and the stream went dry it's
pretty amazing to see happen but you
know if you suck enough water outlet
stream the stream can't keep filling up
that area and it will go dry that's
pretty wild 1i rate is also concerning
us is the installation of water
withdrawal wells on top of the plateau
you know Murray only got a thin layer
soil up there before you hit bedrock and
those thin soils have small wetlands if
you start pulling water from that
plateau your cone depressions going to
start dropping and those wetlands may
not be wet anymore now there aren't any
of those permitted I believe yet in the
areas that we're worried about I think s
rbcs denied all of them but I've stood
next to one that was installed it's just
not operating
our streams and municipalities streams
of municipalities yeah like desiccating
the phone changing to ground water table
into critical areas well in the
Susquehanna River Basin that that's
that's heavily regulated by the srbc so
that you don't see that effect that's
why they are quantifying the water
withdrawals across all users and that's
how they argue they came up with that
low-flow policy so that you cannot have
that effect that you're worried about
because if the streams get to that point
we don't care how they got there we're
shutting you all off so if I own the
town so you know there's townships to
have their own water supply i could sell
water to a gas company treated you know
that's fresh water yeah that mike some
of it also can be water just pulled from
the source the stream that they own or
the well filled
way across the landscape especially on
the credit man that I wonder if he could
maybe speak a little bit more about
different
solutions there might be two addressing
that lack of planning that we do see on
this state lands
so the lack of planning is more on the
private land it's not the state on the
state land it's theirs it's literally a
debate that goes on in the room and
sometimes at the bait leaves the room
and it's between houston and
Pennsylvania's government on private
land though it depends on two things do
you own your mineral rights if you don't
own your mineral rights are called
severed rights okay and if you don't own
the rights you don't have a lot of say
to what happens we do know in the
mineral rights you a lot more power in
your lease negotiation and in that case
you can tell the company we really don't
want the pipeline going across this area
there have been some instances where
some people have tried to stop a
pipeline because they're the one
property that has not agreed to let the
pipeline cross and then those cases go
up to the Pennsylvania Court system but
there is there's really very little
large-scale planning that goes into
where the pipeline is going to go that
it has the least environmental impact a
lot of it has to do with the economics
of getting the pipeline there and the
companies will work to avoid areas they
have to avoid you know if it's regulated
the wetland crews will start walking
those wetlands will be documented if
there's a taking there'll be a
reclamation for that wetland somewhere
else a mitigation and they are by law
required to look for certain species you
know there's an act in Pennsylvania that
requires them to do certain surveys for
wildlife in order to avoid those
habitats and they will avoid those but
there are limits to what can be done
because of Pennsylvania's Commonwealth
law and the lack of regional planning in
a lot of these areas being developed and
the fact that you know the resources the
companies have are tremendous and you
know you know I got to qualify this I
don't mind working with the company's a
lot of my friends that I used to work
with before they work for the company's
worked for the state and it's the same
person it's just the goals of what
they're trying to do differ because of
the economics of that company and I'm
not trying to justify gas in this sense
that it's the best thing that ever
happened to Pennsylvania but no way are
you ever going to negotiate something
and then just have
one sided win and anything you do in
life that's pretty rare and if you're
doing that odds are is going to burn you
down the end anyway because you just
dominating situation too much and you're
not compromising the success that I've
seen comes in Pennsylvania has come
because of compromise and in real Italy
at the end of the day if the gas
companies have really come around in a
lot of cases not all there are some
areas that are absolutely gorgeous that
have been developed and it stinks but I
had a guy and we were talking about this
at lunch today he has a son in the
military in the Middle East and he has a
gas well and he does not like the fact
that his sons in the Middle East
fighting a war which he said not me is
largely because of oil but he has a gas
well in his yard so his sons kid may not
have to do that in the future it's a
complicated situation that touches at
the very core of what an ethic or a
value is for a land or a human condition
you know I've had men who were 70 year
old stand in front of me and cry because
they realized they didn't know in the
mineral rights in the area they hunted
with their grandfather when they were
six years old is gone you know that's
why I do this it's hard to do this
because you see every day what is going
on but you also have it occur incredible
chance to do something as a professor to
make a difference and that's in this
situation that's really why I do this
job but you've got to be careful if you
go in there flaming guns no one's going
to listen and you know how we can
address the private lands issue if we
can figure that out in Pennsylvania with
this you'll have done a tremendous thing
to help Pennsylvania because that's our
biggest problem
what you said I know it's a difficult
task to address the private land
management but how do you envision it be
managed it should be an institution a
coalition to in a private sector and the
state authorities what would I do yeah I
like the idea of Conservancy's you know
I think there should be a fun created
from the gas money in Pennsylvania used
by lands in reserve in conjunction with
the gas companies where you you're going
to sacrifice some areas right that are
going to be developed other areas you're
not going to touch I would stop all
development on state land because those
are the last areas have been tacked for
us we have their managed and then start
buying up the private land tracts like
the melon estate down south you know
that protecting that you know we have
some large tracks left in Pennsylvania
that are just gorgeous that's what I
would do because you're not you can't
take it politically that's not going to
help anyone that's just going to cause
more civil strife and we've got enough
of that in this society now you got to
remunerate someone somehow and there's
plenty of money to do that thanks very
much